todd republican lawmakers are now
demanding a hearing on the biden
administration's broken promises on the
pandemic calling the president's actions
quote a dereliction of duty joining me
now kentucky congressman james comer
congressman good morning to you you and
house minority whip steve scalise are
calling for
a joint hearing on um to discuss
president biden's pandemic response but
of course democrats need to agree to
this so will this hearing happen and
what is your ultimate goal
well we hope the hearing happens
nancy pelosi created the covid select
subcommittee which is a subcommittee of
my
house oversight committee just to try to
look supposedly look into covet issues
and how the government could be better
uh suited for response but what we've
now learned is that she really created
the committee just to try to embarrass
trump because now we have uh the first
year of the bible administration with
respect to covet has been marked by
nothing but broken promises and overall
failure so we want to have a hearing we
haven't had dr fauci or any
anyone from hhs or anyone testify before
the select committee or the overall
oversight committee we have a lot of
questions the american people deserve
answers and we're calling
to do our job and hold a hearing yeah
i'm sure you have a lot of questions and
some of those may be answered today
because cdc director rachelle wolinski
and dr fauci will be testifying before a
senate panel and this is coming at a
critical time for the cdc because
a lot of people
the cdc has a huge credibility issue
right now many people are questioning a
lot of their decision making and
messaging what sort of questions do you
think should be asked there and what are
you hoping to learn
well through the work of the house
oversight committee we've been able to
find some of the redacted emails
from the initial stages of uh when covid
first came about uh prior to dr fauci's
coming out and and saying that this had
to be from animal to human there will be
some questions asked in this committee
that will be a direct response of some
of the work that the house republicans
have done on the house oversight
committee so
i think the american people deserve
answers why doesn't joe biden have a
plan he promised america he would have a
plan he promised america that kovit
would be over with by christmas he
promised america that we would have an
abundance of testing kits now we know
all of these are broken promises so we
need to know what the national plan is
moving forward we all had hoped that
covid would be over with by now but now
we're seeing more talk of shutdowns
we're seeing more talks of
actions by teachers unions to go back to
remote learning this isn't what the
american people want we need to get back
to normal and we need to know what
exactly is the body administration's
plan well congressman speaking of
shutdowns back when president biden was
just a candidate he promised to shut
down the virus that didn't happen but
take a listen to some of his promises on
the campaign trail here
as i said before
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down the virus i'll
shut down the virus not the economy i'm
not going to shut down the country but
i'm going to shut down the virus i'm
going to shut down the virus and build
the economy
you know congressman running out of time
here but really quickly um he made this
promise repeatedly
it didn't happen of course because no
one person can shut down a virus
what does this mean for polling and his
legacy going forward
well not only did he not shut down the
virus there were more deaths in his
first year in office than
during the whole trump administration
from covet so this is not just a broken
promise this is an overall failure and
what we're seeing now are americans
wanting to be able to purchase testing
kits
implied during the campaign that every
american would have access to testing
kits for free uh he's pushing
boosters he's required he's wanting to
mandate boosters when he said in the
campaign he wouldn't do that so we need
to hear from the body administration on
exactly what their plan is over the next
12 months what's their plan moving
forward because we can't afford any more
uncertainty in our economy our children
cannot go back to virtual learning we
have to get back to normal but
unfortunately i'm not seeing any signs
out of the body administration that
would give me any confidence i know the
american
confidence either in the way that i had
it
thank you so much for joining us this
morning